I have torn plenty of on
Twitter I had gone off on rants that I
kind of regret maybe not but I knew when
I was doing in that from doing stand-up
from doing performance art I'm used I'm
very comfortable with that that is a
transaction I have done for decades now
I've pissed people off or taking
pictures for all kinds of stuff so I
that's part of my job that's you if no
one's telling the truth than the truth
that's our stuff then the truth doesn't
get told so if
if we have to play nice with everybody
we have to you know I choose my peers my
peers don't choose me just because I
make a web series if you make a web
series does not mean that we are peers
I've been doing this
decades I didn't start two years ago
three years ago 05 I was doing this
before you too so you're not my peer
just because we vote tell stories online
my peers are people that I know that I
respect that I work with who your spare
me who understand my philosophies those
are my peers my peers are because we're
both pay membership dues to some
volunteer run the circle jerk
or if we're if we have Ward's or
whatever we're not here we're peers
because I say we people were peers not
because you say work we're not a
community just because we're independent
storytellers that's like saying Los
Angeles is a community what lots angels
is a million communities saying
independent story telling us one thing
new media is one thing web series is one
thing it's so stupid there's no
mainstream in a dependent within those
categories of billion subcategories and
on a tiny little fragment of nothing go
go to my IMDB page there's not been
there nobody but the audience who knows
what I do that's who I'm somebody to and
that's what all I care about
because I don't yeah I don't get I don't
get hired by the audience and fired by
the
we have our I tell stories they help me
tell stories
pretty easy business plan again not for
everybody sponsors know they want that
number awards they want that number but
audiences they just care about stories
even with you even if you tell stories
with actors no one's heard oh is it a
good story how many stories have won
Oscars would completely unknown case
unknown directors that happens it's
not just it's number one at the box
office it's not the number one rated
show you know again arrest development
family guy he shows that got cancelled
are now coming back after years of an
audience filled that's the matrix that's
the thing we can may have over them we
can tell story worldwide we can keep
going do you don't have to have weekly
ratings we don't hit me hit box office
we don't need to think about that we
don't need to think about awards you can
change the rules change the way things
happen and not emulate all these systems
new gain new way to do things new
systems new validation systems all new
individuals we each come up with our own
way to do it our own individual business
plans you don't need validation from
anyone other than audience and you'll
need that much validation as an indie
storytellers keep going cuz you're
looking for an Oscar Jesus you better be
eating carbohydrates every goddamn day
because that is a long run and it's and
it's an empty area I'd rather I'd rather
entertain real people and hear from real
people then leave some unknown body of
whatever so they say good job that's
that's not really it's not King
me at all
stirring with a pork
you